dr carlson is taking on the left screen
agenda in a brand new must-see episode
of his original series and here's a
preview of blown away the people versus
wind power which is available on fox
nation right now
texas has the most wind power capacity
in the united states
but the texas turbines which are not
winterized iced up during a cold weather
event in february of 2021
electricity output collapsed you have
all this federal and state subsidies for
wind and solar that have caused an
overbuilding of wind and solar in texas
it's cheap energy
big companies love it they love to
virtue signal with it the texas grid
like the california grid is becoming
increasingly unreliable and difficult to
maintain difficult to keep that power
in a steady basis
all right tucker we're going to take it
around the table and let's begin with
dagon mcdowell
uh tucker we've seen this happen in the
in britain in the north sea where the
wind turbines stopped to spin in and
energy prices went up like 11 times
normal levels this is where we're going
right
well for sure because there are all
kinds of incentives i mean this wouldn't
exist without taxpayer subsidies even
people who are open to the idea of
alternative energy like me
are kind of shocked you know the deeper
you look at this at the effect on the
natural world on the environment itself
by wind farms this stuff is terrible for
the environment actually the closer you
look at it's terrible for animals it's
terrible for the landscape
including endangered animals by the way
several people who live nearby and
that's why all of these installations
are in poor areas that don't vote
for the politicians you put them there
period
tucker harold ford it's been a long time
it's good to see you
as we think about wind turbines and
batteries for electric vehicles and
solar panels
china is leading us in producing and
manufacturing and developing these
things and normally china is not so
transparent when they're trying to uh
beat us in something we saw last week
the hypersonic that fast missile that
they developed that surprised us that's
right how do we reconcile are they doing
this should we just continue to let them
do this because this is not going to be
a benefit to them or do we think about
ways have you heard from some of the
people you've been interviewing about
ways in which we can make this a green
energy
agenda more efficient or these products
are better and more reliable
well i mean the area where china's
really leading us is in coal power i
mean they're continuing to build massive
numbers of coal plants the divide in
carbon emissions between the us and
china is no longer even close it's
multiples of our carbon output which i
think we should note at the very
beginning of any conversation about
global warming but look we don't have
the capacity to build we don't have the
materials the rare earth materials among
others we don't have the manufacturing
capacity to make the green energy
so-called projects of the by
administration is now calling for so by
definition when we start building these
along the both coasts soon
that's china's win like they're the ones
gonna be making them for us period and
the batteries
tucker how would you suggest the
american people stop the building of
some of these because right now they're
putting in a bunch of these turbines off
the coast of long beach island at the
jersey shore and all the fishermen are
appalled because it's going to destroy
their prime fishing waters and they
can't sell the fish to all the people
that want to eat the fish at the shore
how would you suggest people combat this
well i mean again there's a re if you
look at where wind farms are i happen to
live near one they're almost exclusively
in places that are economically
depressed and so they've been kind of
taken advantage of
by
these mostly foreign wind power
companies the way to fight back i think
the environmental community to the
extent there are any honest people left
in it could play a huge role in this
you're destroying a fishery i mean
there's a lot of evidence that these
things are killing may make the
california condor extinct for example
sending whales on the you know in the
wrong direction interfering with the
natural sonar of marine life i mean
these things have a terrible effect on
the environment and so it would be nice
for the environmental community to say
something about that good tucker i
remember about i think maybe a year or
so ago my aunt patty sue former mayor of
rawlins wyoming pointed me to an article
it was actually in the new york times
about a big development of wind power
that was under discussion and the
community was trying to explain to
everybody all the problems that you are
just uh talking about and i i understand
that that's just happening across the
country but there's one other thing that
we haven't mentioned here and that was a
part of that which is
when these wind turbines when the blades
end their life their use for life when
they go into a landfill they do not
disintegrate you could not recycle them
they will be there forever so i i think
that there's just a misunderstanding of
just how really green these are well
that's right there's no painless way to
get energy i mean every energy source
has a downside period whether it's
nuclear hydro coal plants natural gas it
doesn't matter they all have a downside
energy is not free it never will be but
the downside from wind farms
so far exceeds their upside that the
only reason they exist i mean there are
towns and i'm very familiar with some of
these towns in northern new england for
example where the majority of the town's
annual budget comes from wind farm
companies so it's kind of like a deal
they can't refuse they're being preyed
upon because they're weak that's the
underlying story of green energy i would
say
tucker it's greg how are you
so great
thank you for watching hey i want to
talk about the other alternative energy
that we don't hear about anymore
negatively nuclear power why is it do
you why is it i get the feeling that the
democrats have quietly embraced it like
you don't hear about it anymore after
three decades of essentially preventing
it from becoming an option
what changed them why i mean it seems
like there's no anti-nuke movement
anymore
well i mean for one thing that whole
brand of 70s styles
hippies who actually went camping and
cared about the outdoors and lived in
giant sequoias to keep them from cutting
down i mean those people are all gone or
they're right wing at this point okay so
the constituency died that's the first
thing second if they're not complaining
about an industry that means they're
being funded by the industry so i would
follow the money there but i think
nuclear power is not a crazy look
nuclear power is dangerous all forms of
energy are dangerous like it's just
baked in the cake so you just you have
to make rational decisions we're not
getting to utopia with energy sorry ever
all right thanks a lot tucker and uh i
was shocked that people don't live in
sequoias anymore because i interviewed a
bunch of them a couple years ago i love
those people i do too i love them
they're cool people they are they are
all right blown away the people versus
wind power is streaming right now on fox
nation hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else